murmurs letter to his publisher switch
was a part of his page for Song of Ice
and Fire in 1993 it does contain some
potentially major spoilers says in the
letter he wrote which five characters
will survive the events of Game of
Thrones so if you don't want anything
spoiled it's time for you to close this
video
not long ago fence notice that fade from
the okay bookseller waterstones which
contained three photos of a letter from
1993 that Marni has written outlining
the entire series the three it has since
been deleted but not before many fans
screenshotted revealing information in a
series known for killing of main
characters you may be relieved to know
that some Game of Thrones heroes are
safe or least they were in Georgia Mars
original plan for the series before I
get straight into those letters let's
firstly highlight that Martinez he
stated himself may not I prepare through
all clients like some authors but it
still has firm views and exactly very
stories going he said as you know I
don't outline my novels I find that if I
know exactly where book is going I'll
also interesting writing it I do however
have some strong notions as to the
overall structure of the story I'm
telling and the eventual fate of many of
the principal characters in the drama he
added the cast will not always remain
the same all characters will die a new
ones will be introduced some of the
fatalities will include sympathetic
viewpoint characters so who will live
and who will die
George submitted a general outline for
the dent planned trilogy as Song of Ice
and Fire
the series eventually grew to a now
planned set of seven books and has
changed a lot from his starting plot
points but I hope one section of the
general plan has remained a part of
Martin's overall story after telling the
editorial review word that the cast of
characters would be ever-changing with
lots of unexpected deaths Martin makes
it clear that five key protagonists all
survived of course this could have
changed by now but back in 1993 Martin
listed Daenerys Targaryen or star
Johnson on brain stark interior
Lannisters the only major characters
surviving Game of Thrones five central
characters who make it through all three
volumes however growing from children to
adults and changing the world and
themselves in the process Martin wrote
in a sense my trilogy is almost a
generational saga are telling the life
stories of these five characters three
men and two women the five key players
are Tyrion Lannister Daenerys Targaryen
and three of the children of Winterfell
Arya brain and the best Sir John Snow
it's worth noting that all these
characters are still alive in the show
which has long passed the events of the
book series so if fans are to be
optimistic and take Mars original word
at face value Tyrion
sorry brain and John could survive the
entire series
John technically died but was shortly
after brought back to life in the
television adaptation something that
fans can expect to see in the coming
books see if the fan theories are
correct killing him off for a second
time would be unlikely now let's take a
look on one Martin had to say about the
game of Thrones in 1993 here's the
original three-page outline George r
Martin wrote for game thrills dear Ralph
here the first 13 chapters under so many
pages of the high fantasy novel I
promised you which I'm calling a game of
Thrones when completely this will be the
first volume in what I see as an epic
trilogy with the overall title Song of
Ice and Fire
as you know I don't outline my novels I
find that if I know exactly where a book
is going I lose all interesting writing
it I do however have some strong notions
as to the overall structure of the story
I'm telling and the eventual fate of
many of the principal characters in the
drama roughly speaking there are three
major conflicts set in motion in the
chapters enclosed this will form the
major plot threads of the trilogy each
other in what should be a complex but
exciting each of the presents a major
threat of my imaginary realm the Seven
Kingdoms centered alive principal
characters the first thread grows from
the enmity between the great houses of
Lannister and Stark as it plays out in a
cycle of plot counter plot ambition
murder and revenge with the Iron Throne
of the Seven Kingdoms as the ultimate
prize this will form the backbone of the
first volume of trilogy a Game of
Thrones
by the line of Lannister and our wolf of
Starks snarling scrap however a second
and greater threat takes shape across
the Narrow Sea where to the tracking
horse Lords master barbarian horse for a
great invasion of the Seven Kingdoms led
by the fierce and beautiful Daenerys
Stormborn the last of the Targaryen ring
Lords did the track invasion will be the
central story of my second volume a
dance with dragons the greatest danger
of fall however comes from the north
from the icy wastes beyond the wall
where have forgotten demons out of
legend in human errors race code legions
of the undead and never born and
prepared to ride down on the weights of
winter to extinguish everything that we
would call life the only thing that
stands between the Seven Kingdoms and an
endless night is the wall and a handful
of men in black called a nice watch
their story will be hard to mitered
volume the winds of winter the final
battle will also Joker characters and
plot threads left from the first two
books then resolved all in my huge
climax the 13 chapters on hand should
give you a notion as to my narrative
strategy all three books will feature a
complex mosaic of inner cutting points
of view among various
so my large and diverse cast of players
the cast will not always remain the same
old characters will die new ones will be
introduced some of the fatality it's
will include sympathetic viewpoint
characters I want the reader to feel
that no one is ever completely safe not
even the characters will seem to be the
heroes this suspense always ratchets up
a notch when you know that any character
can die at any time five central
characters will make it roll three
volumes however growing from children to
adults and changing the world in
themselves in the process in a sense my
trilogy is almost a generational saga
telling the life stories of these five
characters three men and two women the
five key players are Tyrion Lannister
Daenerys Targaryen and three of the
children on Winterfell Arya brain and
the bastard Jon Snow
all of them are introduced at some
length in the chapters you have to hand
this is going to be I hope quite an epic
epic 1/8 scale epic in its action and
epic in its length
I see all three volumes as big books
running about 700 to 800 manuscript
pages so things are just barely getting
under way in the 13 chapters I've sent
you I have quite a clear notion of how
the story is going to unfold in the
first volume of Game of Thrones things
will get a lot worse for the poor stars
before they get better I'm afraid Lord
Eddard Stark and his wife Catelyn Tully
are both doomed and will perish at the
hands of their enemies Ned will discover
what happened to his friend Jon Arryn
connect on his knowledge we'll have
unfortunate accident and the throne will
too embroidered Joffrey is still a minor
Joffrey will not be sympathetic and
Edward Pierce to say will be accused of
treason but before he's taken he will
help his wife in his daughter Arya
escape back to Winterfell each of the
contending families will learn it has a
member of dubious loyalty in its midst
sends a stark white to Joffrey Baratheon
will bear him a son the heir to the
throne and when the crunch comes she'll
choose her husband and child over her
parents and siblings a choice Shiva
later bitterly Roo dear Lannister
meanwhile will be friend both sense and
her sister Arya while crying more and
more disenchanted with his own family
young bran will come out of his coma
after strange prophetic dream only to
discover that he will never walk again
he will turn to magic at first in the
hope of restoring his legs but later for
its own sake when his father Eddard
Stark is executed brain will see the
shape of doom descending on all of them
but nothing he can say will stop his
brother Rob from calling the banners in
rebellion all the north will be inflamed
by war Robb will win several spent
victories sent maim Joffrey Baratheon in
the battlefield
but in the end he will not be able to
say engage
in Tyrion Lannister in their lies Robb
Stark will die in battle and Tyrion
Lannister will besiege and burn
Winterfell Jon Snow the bastard will
remain in the far north
he will mature into Ranger great daring
and ultimately will succeed his uncle as
the commander of the night's watch when
Winterfell burns Catelyn Stark will be
forced to flee north with her son bran
and her daughter Arya wounded by Lance
Riders they will seek refuge at the wall
but the men of the Nights Watch give up
their families when they take the black
and Jon and benjin will be able to help
to John's anguish it will lead to a
bitter strange meant between Jon and
brain Arya will be more forgiving until
she realizes with terror that she has
fallen in love with John who is not only
her half-brother but a man of the Nights
Watch stoned to celibacy
their passion will continue to torment
Jon in target throughout the trilogy
until the secret of Joshu parentage is
finally revealed in the last book
abandoned by the Nights Watch Kathleen
and her children will find their only
hope of safety life's even further north
beyond the wall where they fall into the
hands of Mance Rayder the
king-beyond-the-wall and get a dreadful
glimpse of the human errors as they
attacked the Wilding encampment burns
magical sword needle and the savagery of
their dire walls will help them survive
better mother Kathleen will die at the
hands of the others or across an air of
seed and heirs Targaryen will discover
that her new husband at the track he
called javac has little interest in
invading the semi kingdoms much to her
brother's frustration maybe there's
presses exclaims past the point of tact
or wisdom Khal Drogo finally grew
annoyed and killing him out of hand
eliminating Targaryen pretender and
leaving the nurses the last of her line
the near so bite her time but she will
not forget when the moment is right
she'll kill her husband to venture
brother and then flee with a trusted
friend into the wilderness beyond waste
attract their hunted by of her life she
stumbles on and something about dragon
eggs
a young dragon will give the nearest
bend to her will then she begins to plan
for her invasion of the Seven Kingdoms
Tyrion Lannister will continue to travel
to plot and to play the game of Thrones
final removing his nephew Joffrey in
disgust at the boy Kings brutality Jaime
Lannister will follow Joffrey on the
throne of the Seven Kingdoms
by the simple expedient of killing
everyone heard of him in the line of
succession and blaming his brother
Tyrion for the murders exiled Tyrion
will change sides make a common cause
with the surviving Starks to bring his
brother down and falling helplessly in
lavatories Stark while he's at it
his passion is alas and reciprocated but
no less intense for that and it will
lead to a deadly rivalry between Tyrion
and Jon Snow the next
Graff is blocked out but at the second
book I hope you will find somewhere
excited about all of this as I am
feel free to share its letter written
one who wants to know how the story will
go all best george RR martin from the
initial three novels the series so now
and it's seven obviously many Martin's
plans for novels may have changed since
then but if you follow both the books
and show the five characters George said
would survive the game of Thrones seems
to wear the most spot Armour the more
important part is that all these five
characters are still very important for
the plot development fans will be
thrilled to know that he fully intend in
five major fictional favorites to
survive although this leads the fate of
some matters hanging precariously in the
balance some of the most loved
characters such as census turkey and
Jaime Lannister but in this case most
likely died as gammatron sending without
at least half of the main characters
dying would not be the bittersweet
ending we've been promised